le contrat forêt bois de bourgogne
franche comté c'est un peu son bébé
sylvain mathieu vice président de la
région a orchestrée durant trois ans les
concertations entre tous les acteurs
publics et privés de la filière et pour
remplir cette mission
il n'était pas le plus mal placé
quelques heures avant la session c'est
droit dans ses bottes que nous avons
retrouvé celui qui fut ingénieur
forestier à l'eau et 9 avant de se
lancer en politique
là au milieu des êtres il nous rappelle
d'abord les données de base du sujet une
forêt quelle qu'elle soit ou qu'elle
soit toujours trois fonctions une
première fonction de production de bois
dont c'est la fonction économique
une deuxième fonction de protection des
espèces des milieux de la ressource en
eau la biodiversité c'est sa fonction
écologique
et puis une troisième fonction d'accueil
du public une fonction récréative
c'est ce qu'on appelle la fonction
sociale une politique forestière doit
donc conjuguer ces trois fonctions de la
manière la plus équilibrée possible
certains objectifs sont chiffrables par
exemple augmenter la récolte de bois
d'oeuvre feuillus de 15% d'ici 2028
parfois c'est plus délicat comment
préparer la forêt au changement
climatique
on va aller probablement vers de plus en
plus d'épisodes d'étés chauds et secs
des épisodes de sécheresses canicules
qui peut être mortelle pour beaucoup
d'essences d'arbres qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui sous d'autres latitudes
donc on pourrait se dire il suffit
d'anticiper en allant chercher des
essences méditerranéennes et d
introduire chez nous mais ce n'est pas
si simple parce que on aura au corps
encore des épisodes de divers
relativement froid qui peuvent être
mortelles pour des essences
méditerranéennes
pour autant c'est bien la problématique
économique qui constitue l'essentiel du
contrat forêt bois avec la volonté
affichée de renforcer la compétitivité
de la filière